[Music]
all the time you did the show did any
actress afterwards like did you call her
or go listen I felt some connection
would you like to go out on a date did
you ever try there was one at the very
beginning and it was a bad man tracer
singer everything I have a Sharon Stone
Oh Sharon Stone yeah yeah yeah I had you
know I felt like I mean nothing ever
happened we just had dinner right you
have dinner and it's a flirtation right
right and she was very nice and then she
went away and but the whole time I got
to be honest the whole time I was
thinking about that scene and big oh my
god yes is she wearing underwear I mean
a physically beautiful woman but you
couldn't close the deal so to speak you
know Alfred
was there no connection there was no
real chemistry there it was like she was
very nice yes but that but then it was
like I I think she felt awkward and I
feel awkward and I was like well that
was great we shook hands and Doctor Who
you mind yourself interviewing her a
little bit yeah a little bit like so and
then what happened stuff I cannae have a
kind of weird just think she could have
been Sharon Ferguson yeah I think I
think we both survived that quite well